back to our coverage of the Karen's cup
as we have five exciting games underway
including one in which the world
champion could have bitten off more than
she can chew she looks like she might be
in a very tough position yeah so you're
gonna certainly keep our eyes peeled on
that no question about it catcher
looking at a really great opportunity
with Bishop d4 but we have a very
special guest in studio yeah it's one of
the flagship programs now of the st.
Louis Cheska of their chest cops program
and with us we have Kristie marks
captain and she is with Alejandra
Ramirez welcome here to this show
captain marks
well Ches we've seen it all on the
studio we see all this amazing
tournaments but at the core of the st.
Louis Chess Club is community outreach
and we have this wonderful program chess
cops tell us all about it
well chess cops is a program where they
have the children from the st. Louis
City Public Schools interact with police
officers and they meet across the
chessboard and that experience over the
past year when I've been involved has
been absolutely exciting breathtaking
and something that has really changed
the way I see these youth and a lot of
my officers have absolutely feeling the
same way that's more about this program
it's how is it that the community has
reacted to playing chess well I can tell
you how my officers and the students
that were playing chess with have
reacted my officers have been asking me
I just been recently reassigned to a new
district and they've been asking me kid
they come with me and get involved and
they when we walked away from our last
events last week but the life Alif
Academy they were like when's the next
one so they were so excited that the
young minds when you're playing a middle
schooler or even a grade schooler across
the chessboard and they're better at
chess than you
that's pretty eye-opening is pretty
exciting for what our future has in
store well trust us we feel the same way
as Grand Master says one of the players
that this tournament is actually a
teenager not quite a middle schooler but
we've seen the talent
comes out of st. Louis we've had great
players coming from here how would you
feel this program is different than
other community outreach that what cops
do with their with their community you
think the competition the friendly
competition helps a lot it does but I
think what I think I'm seeing is that
one-on-one interaction when we do
community engagement
often at schools and so forth it's
usually not one-on-one and the great
thing about being across that chessboard
playing the entire game a lot of
conversation ensues during that game and
we learn a lot about each other there
things about me that I've disclosed to
some of the students I've played with
and they're like no way I would never
believe that and there's so many things
I'm learning about them so I think that
one in one dynamic we don't have a lot
of chance to do that and this is a great
opportunity to make that happens that
it's actually a great point the chess of
course we have all this community
outreach program at the end of the day
and it's one-on-one conversation we like
to think of chess a lot of the times
like that and you feel that's brought
you a lot closer with some people that
perhaps you wouldn't have been able to
in a group setting yes and we don't
usually get the time to go one-on-one
with a lot of the kids in the community
and this has been a great opportunity
and what about the level of chess here
do you think some of your officers have
gotten really competitive about it where
is it more of a chill environment I
think a lot of my officers including
myself have been humbled because some of
these young students they're really good
we have a lot of outreach here so
they're getting training by pretty good
people very very good chess well it
seems like your son is an avid player
tell us a little bit about that he is on
the middle of my dining room table is a
chess board so he is ten years old and
he takes chess after school but he
challenges me all the time and I brought
him to a couple events and he loves it
he's like mom can I not go to school can
I come with you and I can't let him
however I did ask him preparing for this
I said Christian what is it about chess
that you love so much because my son is
very hyperactive and a little
scatterbrained he's the hot mess Express
and it was really interesting and I'm so
glad I asked him because he actually
told me just last night he said mom it's
one of the only things that calm me down
and help me focus which is a struggle
that he has at school so I found it very
eye
opening even for myself as a mother that
this is a game that has brought him some
peace and he was even able to articulate
that to me and that is one of the great
things about chess and it's a common
story in our chess world including our
number one player Fabiana Khurana he got
started in chess
basically as a way of that's do you say
calming down and it's proved to be
pretty successful here that I'm making a
bit of a career out of it yes tell us a
little bit more about I heard there's a
breakfast coming up on March there is I
think it's the second annual breakfast
with the chest with cops program and so
we are hoping that everyone comes out
and supports this great cause and I'm
and of course be trying to remind all of
my officers and bring them and hopefully
that will be able to come and attend and
make this second one a great one
Thursday March 19th there you have all
the information that gets available at
st. Louis chess club door org I'll
definitely be trying to make it out
there March 19th yeah definitely be
there well thank you here for joining us
this is I think just such a great
community outreach I'm very happy the
club can be part of it guys we have a
ton of games to get back to has Locke
know made a move well I do want to give
an invitation open invitation to captain
Christie Marcus we do have our Thursday
night ladies night chess classes wine
cheese and chess so if you're looking
for a moms night out and a few tips to
maybe help you beat those kiddos we have
it open invite for you there thank you
you